so we've just established why we care
about these things number one you can
solve interesting problems in their own
right with series and sequences and
number two this is going to this very
big important topic in calculus called
integration whatever that means
so we're trying to lay some groundwork
so if we care about these objects then
we want to be able to describe them or
to find them in a bunch of different
ways and just like I've got three items
they're coincidentally I have three ways
of showing you how to define a
progression the first way is already on
the board so this is number one the
first way is if you want to talk about a
sequence or a series you just start
listing out the terms the first way is
the list okay now when you have a list I
gave you more than you needed there you
need a minimum of three objects to talk
about what the sequence of series is so
you can you know conclusively what it is
you need three objects minimum three to
establish the pattern let me illustrate
this very easily for you if I said 1
comma 2 and this sequence was going to
go on right at the moment with just
those two numbers you don't know what
comes next
can someone give me an example of what
could come next that was perfect
okay so for instance most people who
could say the next thing would be 3 so
these are the counting numbers right I'm
something I haven't mentioned up here is
that these guys here are what we would
call finite sequences or series they end
right but I'm about to make this an
infinite sequence don't don't so these
are the counting numbers no big deal
with the third term I can describe ok
I'm adding 1 each time that's what makes
this sequence what it is but I didn't
have to write I could have just as
easily said 4 and this is no longer the
set of counting numbers 1 2 3 4 5 what
would be the term after 4 8 and then 16
and 32 so these are the powers of 2 okay
so either of these are legitimate lists
in fact both of these are pretty
important cases we'll have a look at
later but this is the simplest way this
is the simplest way
to define a particular progression just
tell me how the progression starts and
get me a little bit in so I can
establish the pattern so that is the
first way okay the second way is when
I'm going to borrow back from binomial
theorem in term one if you recall that
right when we said you've got some kind
of actually I'll do that I'll do the
general one if you've got some kind of
binomial expansion right we used Singh
notation we said look this is going to
have a whole bunch terms in this case
this particular one's gonna have how
many terms and plus one so I could say
that's the sum of hmm that's interesting
this is the sum of a whole bunch of
terms what terms would there be
you'd start from sorry that's an R
that's a bad typo you'd start from zero
you'd go all the way up until and and
then what's the thing that you're going
to add up what's the thing you're gonna
add up I'll give you a clue it's got one
two three pieces in it
okay it's gonna start with the actual
binomial coefficient so and see ah and
then what comes next
yeah there'll be some of these there
will be some A's and there will be a
power here I mean we could do this
either way maybe I'll make that ah and
then along with the A's they're also
going to be these some number of those
such that these two things add up to n
okay now what is this thing see this
thing over here this is what we'd called
the general term the general term and
this is another way to define a
progression in fact that's why we use it
for binomial theorem because a binomial
is even though we never labeled it as
such
it's a series did you see that it's a
bunch of things with order and you add
them up okay so we've actually been
dealing with this object for quite some
time so a general term how do we say
this we would say T and equals right so
you'd read this as the nth term
and then you use addresses is a bit like
a function to describe things however
you like let's have a look to say this
term over here or this sequence I should
say 1 2 4 etc what would the general
term be for this particular sequence
well we said this was the powers of 2
right so I guess I would say that this
is 2 to the power of 0 to the power of 1
should have 2 and so on
ok now even though with binomial theorem
we have very good reasons to do this we
usually start with 0 when we float back
over to series of sequences in general
there's no overarching reason to start
from 0 does they don't remember the
reason we did stuff from 0 for these
guys it's because of Pascal's triangle
the way binomial coefficients work the
way this thing is structured with the
factorials all that kind of thing
starting with 0 made sense ok but when
you're talking about any kinds of
sequence to the series that you like
there's no reason to necessarily start
at 0 so I'm gonna just going to call
this term one term two ten three so what
would the very first term be i'll give
you clue it starts with the two because
they are all powers of two do you see
that okay so if I want the nth term
right for example the first term has
this power being 0 the second term has
this power being 1 the third term has
this power being 2 so the power is
always 1 less then then the actual term
that I'm up to is that true so this
would be n minus 1 wouldn't it you see
that that's the term I'm up to and the
power is always 1 less than that ok that
would be the general term how about
something like this here's another list
for you one three five dot dot dot dot
what is this list
what is this sequence these are the odd
numbers right these are the odd numbers
so what would the nth term for this look
like
when you think about this right another
easy way to compare this to is that this
sequence is a lot like the these are the
odd numbers right this sequence is a lot
like this sequence here which is the
even numbers right but it turns out the
even numbers are a little bit easier to
wrap your head around because the even
numbers are just 2 times 1 and 2 times 2
and 2 times 3 yeah so the first term is
2 times 1 the first term the second term
is 2 times 2 the second term so this
sequence here is just going to be 2m
do you agree that's the general term
right but I'm interested in the odd
numbers I don't want the even numbers
but what I do to turn the even numbers
into the odd numbers yeah you just
subtract that'd do it for you right so
you see this this here every term in the
sequence of odd numbers looks like this
and if you want a specific one you just
supply a specific end that make sense ok
so number one list number two general
term the third one is the fanciest it's
the weirdest it's the least common but
in some cases it's the best so you'll
see that in a second we call it a
recursion now
recursion is a weird idea when you say
something's like a recurring motif in
English that means it's something that
comes back up again again and again and
it refers back to itself right it's like
oh I see a character do something and
then later on in the story they do the
same thing it's meant to call you back
to the past right a recursion is the
same idea in terms of sequences and I'm
going to give you the most famous
example of a recursion ok term one
equals one term two equals one term and
this okay so before we actually produce
what this thing is let me explain to you
why it's a recursion right it's all
about this line here see this line
remember I said to you in English a
recurring motif is where something
happens that refers back to the past
that it happened before right
we'll see this line here it's like hey
look to get to the next term you need
previous turns right you need to look
back to the past and see what happened
okay so what would happen in this case
what lists would we produce well I've
told you the first two terms already one
one
how do I get the third term yeah you
just you just add these two right just
see that so term three will be term two
plus term one you see that says the
previous two terms so the next one will
be 1 plus 1 which is 2 how do I get the
fourth term I'm going to add these two
terms here turn two and turn 3 so you
get three and then you get five and then
you get so what what sequence have I
produced this is the Fibonacci sequence
so this is a very very famous sequence
this is the most famous example of a
recursion but you can stay any of these
guys here recursively that's the
adjective right all it means is you need
a starting point and then a rule that
tells you to progress in fact that's so
important that idea I'm just going to
define it here maybe you want to write
it with me
you need a starting point and then you
need to how do I advance okay
that's what recursion is where as a
general term is a rule for each
individual term whereas a list is just
enough of the sequence to see a pattern
so let's have a look at some of these
other guys over here how am i I define
we already just said this is Fibonacci
how am i I define the odd numbers in
terms of a recursion what would I do on
your starting point right where do the
odd numbers begin they begin with one
that's quite common isn't it may begin
with one and then how do I advance how
do I get to the next odd number I just
add two to the previous term right so I
would say the nth term is the term
before it plus two and that will get you
all the way to the rest of the sequence
does that make sense okay so question we
just define it like that most most times
it's a bit weird to start with this
because most recursions only require the
very first term and then to get the next
one you only need that term and then you
do something to it
Fibonacci is one of the few sequences
where you actually need more than one
term every term needs two terms to build
it and so that's why I define each of
those and then off I go